knowing that you're a big analytics guy
what do you see gets the most hits at
filmmaking stuff well my website
filmmaking stuff it's almost it's it's
such a loaded question because when you
ask you know what gets the most hits on
filmmaking stuff in terms of analytics I
have to come up with catchy titles to my
blog post or people don't read that you
know being completely Frank or they read
them but they don't tweet about them or
they don't share them and then I always
feel like well does that mean they're
not engaged but then some days I'll
write those really cool blog posts that
are cool and have a boring name but then
I'll get all sorts of opt-ins to my
email list but nobody's sharing it on
the social media which goes back to my
earlier thoughts about email why I love
you mail so much I don't even know how
to answer your question let me be pretty
completely fresh i think if i do really
catchy if i do a really catchy subject
line that's good because then people
probably read the article if i do a
subject line that that's goofy and
boring with a really great article i
think less people read that article if
that makes sense so it sounds like it
goes back to what you talked about for
filmmaking something that's slightly
polarizing yeah so I think you have to
take a point of view any time that I've
written articles on my site because I
didn't want to offend certain segments
in the filmmaking population you know
then it just comes up being a mundane
boring article but if I go in there and
I'm like distribution has become a
commodity or one of the ones that got a
lot of I got really beat up over one of
them one time I ever at this article
about and it seems obvious to me but I
took I took the same kind of math you
would use for direct mail campaigns you
know whenever you send out a postcard
campaign you know that only like one
tenth and one percent of people are
going to buy so it was like well what if
I apply that to my filmmaker website and
I say a very small percentage of people
by how many units do I have to sell to
get a million dollars in revenue and it
was like I'd set these really like
worst-case scenarios to figure out how
much I would have to spend
in pay-per-click advertising and and I
came up with these different scenarios
and really worked out the formulas and I
got people to double check my math to
make sure I wasn't wacky and then I push
you know publish and the next thing you
know everybody's beating me up like all
my comments are like Jason you know
you'll you can't make a million dollars
this way or you know there were all
these different reasons on why this this
thing would fail and I was like guys i'm
literally doing hypothetical math here
and and everybody took it as the gospel
and i'm not saying it is the gospel and
to this day I'm telling you that's
really good important stuff to know like
knowing what your conversion rate is on
your website is important to know on how
much you're spending advertising is
important to know especially if it's pay
per click and if that number if your
conversion rates not high enough to
support the money you're spending and
advertising so you can make a profit
margin am using my hands as a pantomime
you need if you can't make a profit
margin you can figure that out pretty
quickly that's all I was trying to
express but I think even though that
concept is familiar to a lot of
marketers this goes back to the idea
that he's trying to talk at least the
math aspect of marketing the filmmakers
then it's like their eyes glaze over so
theoretically and in practice if you can
make the numbers work you could just do
a pay-per-click campaign that would pay
for itself every time you make a sale
that sale is far and above what you're
paying for that click so you know you
have to know your conversion rate in
order to do that I hope that didn't get
overly nerdy for everybody but it is a
nerdy concept but if you know this stuff
it's so empowering because now you can
just like you could spend thousands of
dollars in advertising pay-per-click
advertising but you're going to make
your money back each time you sell and
that's like that's so awesome it's so
awesome and that's why I get excited
about filmmaking you know at least some
of these new tools that are available
you